creation and spirit of monday morning
session which i was unable to attend
from what i heard there was a very
spirited discussion and i'd also be
happy to continue that
um so please speak up with any questions
complaints issues
i'm trying this so again this is coming
from perhaps a rather pure uh
theoretical computer science background
and trying to engage with the biologists
here so uh
yeah please uh
speak up
okay so
evolvability um
we've got we've got these functions in
our body that
um are genetic
the mechanisms of life the biochemical
mechanisms of life are computing and the
question is where did they come from in
some sense they are they seem to be well
adapted to the current environment how
do they become well adapted to the
current environment
how when the environment changes will
they continue to adapt
and
so
think of these complicated protein
networks where each connection here is
not just a connection but actually some
sort of function representing
that the concentration of protein v
should be expressed to satisfy some
certain equations some certain relation
between it and the concentrations of
other things how do these um connections
get perfectly
evolved for the for their task or if not
perfectly evolved how do they get
reasonably evolved how do they do
anything useful at all
this picture as you can see
at first glance looks like everything is
connected to everything so there's a
incredibly complicated thing going on
here and how did it
how did it arise how will it continue to
adapt as conditions change
so
evolvability
is the combination of concerns from two
different areas
evolution biological evolution and
pac learning
probably approximately correct learning
uh a model of machine learning from
computer science
um okay so on monday
we saw four talks about this
so
first was the introduction trying to
motivate this and also give you some
impossibility results which
from what i heard were controversial
um
next
vitale feldman gave the
boolean model for evolvability
and showed how you could emulate a very
broad class of machine learning
algorithms from within this model
varun
looked at functions with short
representations because in biology
perhaps the concentration of a certain
protein maybe only depends on the
concentrations of a few other proteins
so maybe there's short representations
for each particular component of what's
happening in life
so can we quickly evolve functions that
are better than you might otherwise
expect
and elaine talked about um
what chemical kinetics tells us about
the kinds of functions the classes of
function that we should be concerned
with modeling here
okay so because monday was a long way
away i'll go back and
try and review the model
and again please
bring your your questions forward
so why is evolution like learning why is
this a reasonable metaphor
and what can this teach us about
evolution or perhaps about learning
so
just to start out what is sort of the
standard learning model
so
we have some function that we're trying
to train we want to train this to be a
better function
and we've got some distribution of
examples that we present the function
and we try and ask the function you know
do something with this example
and if it does the right thing we try to
depending on what it does we try to
train it to be better so as a example
that you guys have all probably seen in
some form
so uh labeling images so perhaps the
distribution is some distribution of
images so you have some database with a
whole bunch of images
and you're trying to train a function to
label these images
so you have some function
it's given an image of a cat
and it returns something it guesses it's
a dog so
then then what happens
well there's some performance evaluation
so you have given it a picture of a cat
your function has said dog
you
compare the desired answer to the actual
answer and
depending upon what happens you try to
update your function to be a little bit
smarter about how it labels things
so this is machine learning
so
nature also plays this game
evolution plays this game everyone plays
this game as part of going through life
so
where
the function that we are trying to
improve is
expressed by your dna your dna
encodes this function but also
chemically enforces this function
your dna chemically enforces how to
respond to different concentrations of
proteins around it
nature gives you examples
and your dna encodes responses to these
examples
so instead of in the top example
presenting your function with a picture
of a cat
in life
nature
throws a physical cat at a cat appears
in front of you
and biochemically your dna enforces some
response to this cat when a cat appears
in front of you
what does your dna encode that you do
so perhaps the chemically encoded
response is that you start sweating
is this a good response is this a bad
response
again nature always evaluates your
performance we are always constantly
being evaluated with the end result
being do we survive and reproduce or do
we die off
there's no way to avoid this nature is
throwing examples at us
our dna is chemically enforcing
relations that respond to these
and then our responses are being
evaluated
is there a clean model that captures all
the aspects of this
no but we can aim for something which at
least tries to capture some of some of
the flavor of this
so again the
more concrete version that we'll try and
model is things like the concentration
of chemicals x and y in your environment
is 0.73 and 0.49 what concentration of
enzyme z will you produce
this is encoded in your dna if we knew
how to read dna in this sense
so the question is how do these
how does this relation between x y and z
evolve
okay
um it's very important both for the
machine learning setting and for
evolution
to quantify this over a very big class
of distributions
and also of course over a
large class of functions
so
this considerable mystery about what
both
the distribution of
state ecology is
and also about
what the
functionality that dna should perform is
so the computer science approach to when
we don't know
um the exact nature of something we
make a broad class of things and say
look let's just pretend it's an unknown
example from this class
one other um don't think that mapping is
complete because in the nature
the dna of that organism of its
relatives and so on feeds back to the
nature
so it's not you know here you have a
one-dimensional flow of information
and that's the machine learning case and
in biology it's not
right um
yes so
there's many kinds of questions you can
ask of a model
the question
which
we're more aiming at is
what kinds of behaviors can you can
analyze in this in the setting
and
it is not true that it doesn't arise in
machine learning it certainly arises
when you trade stocks you influence the
market where you trade it's just a
simpler first approximation to what the
answer is you know trading is an example
where
it also breaks down yes
uh is it gonna be crucial here that
we're asking like what concentration of
enzymes do you produce in that like how
do i make enzyme z better
how do i make enzyme z better you know
adjust how i adjust the protein to make
it work yeah
so
in some sense it's hard to come up with
a quantitative model of
how proteins map to functionality
so we're using this instead
so
again i'm not aiming to capture
everything in the world i'm not even
aiming to capture the richness of
everything in the world i'm aiming to
capture
a problem that we don't understand how
to solve and that i think it's actually
rather
um embarrassing that we don't know how
to solve this
um so so i mean okay just a general
metaphor so suppose you observe some
phenomenon that you can't quite explain
so i'm not sure how many of you go
hiking in the you know mountains around
yosemite but anytime you see a lake you
see fish in the lake how did those fish
get in the lake
so you know you see a phenomenon like
this and you immediately come up with
some guess well okay maybe the fish
swim upstream
and then okay well immediately you
noticed some things which kind of
confound this theory that okay i've
found a waterfall how do the fish jump
up the waterfall and well okay maybe the
first waterfall you find is only this
tall
and if you watch for long enough you'll
eventually see these fish amazingly
enough jumping up this waterfall
but then further on in your day maybe
you'll find a waterfall that's 100 feet
tall and then have the fish get out that
waterfall
and so
suddenly you need a more sophisticated
explanation maybe
further back in time 10 million years
ago the waterfall was smaller and the
fish jumped up there and they've been
living up there for last 10 million
years
and the fact that the mechanism that you
know about that fish can jump up small
waterfalls breaks down this large
waterfall it immediately gives you
insight that
unless you predict some kind of strange
event that you haven't seen before that
may have happened in the
in the distant past
um
so
again you can do all of this you can
infer the existence of a time
when the waterfall is shorter without
having modeled the entire guts of the
fish we're just modeling a certain part
of the fish realizing that our model is
insufficient to explain what's happening
and then saying that
we need a new explanation for it for
this
for this case so i'm not trying to model
all of nature i'm just saying that if
you
try and
uh simplify things the point where
instead of modeling an entire fish you
just say look i don't think a fish can
jump 10 feet in the air
then this already gives you plenty of
insight into things which can and can't
have happened
okay
um
okay yes so i think i want to make one
more detour right now
just to uh
all right so
the
um
no okay i'll make this detail in a few
few minutes um
i'm sorry
clock okay
so
let me just review the model which um
we've seen monday and we'll see again
um
okay right so um
last thing here is uh darwinian
evolution is like machine learning but
machine learning in some sense lets you
do anything to update this function that
you want
um given the data
given your performance evaluation
machine learning is just what what can
we do to make this function better
and
evolution is not unrestricted in this
way evolution has some restrictions
exactly one of these restrictions is of
course up for debate
but um
one kind of restriction you could add is
that
the feedback the dna is survival or
death
the dna doesn't do explicit computations
on your life experiences or at least if
it does this is a you know unusual and
uh it's an unusual mechanism and the
main mechanism of life isn't the dna
computing on your entire life life
experiences listen to pipeline from your
visual cortex to your dna
that it'll figure out you know based on
what you've seen how to edit your dna
for your progeny right
um
so
whatever
learning
can do
we might hope that evolution can do
whatever learning can't do evolution
can't possibly do
because
evolution is a restricted subset of
learning you can't do arbitrary function
you can't do arbitrary operations to
update your dna you can do some certain
restriction of these
okay so
let me introduce the model um
which is a variant what we've seen on
monday and then i'll talk a little bit
more about the philosophy um okay so
nature
has a distribution in end dimensional
space you can think of each of these
dimensions as being the concentration of
some protein that's in our cellular
environment
and
nature also has in mind perhaps
for every particular combination of
n
of these proteins that we care about
right sorry any of these chemicals in
our environment that we care about
um
it describes for each of the m proteins
that we are going to produce what the
best concentration of them to produces
okay so
why m and not one well because we can so
you can say just you know focusing on
one protein what's the ideal
concentration of this one protein
but
there are many proteins that you want to
produce maybe we want to evolve them in
parallel
so you know a
global example is suppose i want to
learn to walk i don't want to evolve
left leg part of walking separately from
right leg part of walking walking only
work so i have two legs working together
so having multiple outputs and trying to
evolve them together
seems like it's something that something
that we need to at least do
and
a creature's dna
somehow encodes and enforces
this function that maps input
concentrations of of chemicals into
expression levels of m different
proteins
okay so
for each creature we're going to model
life as the following game
so
nature has some distribution of input
examples
and
we take several um over the course of
our lifetime we're presented with
several examples nature presents us with
several examples
and then
the creature responds to these examples
by expressing proteins
um
so
given
a sample x
concentrations of all these different
chemicals in our environment
our dna encodes some hypothesis h of x
the ideal response not that we know this
not that anyone happens to know the
ideal response but there is some ideal
response
we can call this f of x
and
for the moment we can say just as a
slightly simplified assumption
that the performance of our feature
we're going to model as just how far is
h of x from f of x
again these are vectors in high
dimensional space so take the vector
distance
and this is a rating of the creature
um
so
for each creature we can rate it
and then
darwin says there's survival of the
fittest
and
there are many many ways to implement
this as it turns out um provably many of
many of them don't matter in this
context but the easiest way is just
the best single creature c survives
and then finally
the crucial thing which we need to
figure out is
how to produce the next generation
offspring from the parent
and then this process repeats
so
we have the following crucial definition
of
evolvability in the in the real numbered
setting
so
a class of functions f
is evolvable
if there exists a mutation algorithm
such that for all distributions
and all possible ideal
functions
ideal responses to the environment
functions in this class
a near optimal hypothesis h will be
found efficiently with high probability
so
this is saying this triple
defined by the class of functions
capital f
the cl the distributions d
hopefully all distributions
um
and uh
i guess the third thing which you might
include here is just that we're using
the quadratic loss function
yeah
uh
yeah so polynomial in all of the
parameters
involved so uh
um in this case
right so uh
discretize the real numbers to whatever
position you want
and then in terms of that
um
so
yes
yeah so uh
to take some number of samples
um and then compute this and take the
average of this over over the samples
so so yes an empirical best not a uh so
you don't even need to take an
expectation so expectation is in some
sense cheating expectation is saying if
we ran the creature for an infinite
number of lifetimes how good would how
good would it be
but um
all you need to do is take some fixed
number of samples corresponding it's
actual lifetime and see in its actual
lifetimes which creatures did best okay
so i mean the fact that it's quadratic
the penalty does that matter much
yeah
um
so
again the kinds of results we're asking
are
so for triple which consists of
um
a class f of functions
a class d of distributions and a loss
function l which at the moment is
quadratic
this thing is evolvable okay
if i replace it with quadratic by
something else
does that change the answer or change
what you can prove it or need i mean oh
um sure so certainly it makes it harder
to prove uh
and
i believe actually people were
complaining on monday that this was too
restrictive but you're saying oh no it
you don't care now
vitaly was saying that it does change
the answer actually
sure sure um
so so change the answer or whether you
can prove it the answer it moves it
moves some functions some class of
functions from polynomial to
non-volatility depending whether it's
linear
so
all all three of these things set up a
landscape
yeah right and they interact in a
complicated way these three things
interact in a complicated way through
this process
i was just asking what was known or
guessed about loosening up this
um
okay towards the end of the talk i'll
definitely talk about loosening this up
but um
well what would you attribute this loss
function to to the nature or to the
person who's trying to learn the
hypothesis
so
you mean the evolving feature
no so the loss function yeah i mean in
evolution
who decides that the
nature of nature yeah and so would
things change if you allow
the existence of some loss function
which could be a turing machine which is
efficient on the outputs um yes so i'm
saying in general we want to ask for
what triples
will you reach neo-optimal behavior in a
reasonable amount of time
so if you're interested in in a certain
class of l
then yes this is a fair question to ask
okay
so this is completely within the scope
of this slide okay
so for what triples fdl
are you going to reach near optimal
performance guaranteed for you know any
function chosen from this for any
distribution chosen from this and for
your loss function l
so so
i'm asking this in in this kind of
generality
there are many different ways that you
can make this problem more more precise
and if i ask the question back within
this class there's a typical um
a typical function in this or typical df
and um
h in this in this class
um is that evolvable rather than the
worst case
right um
so let me get to that in one moment
there's a question here yeah do you not
gain anything with sexual reproduction
or crossover um
yes so you gain something but you don't
gain the difference between polynomial
that's non-polynomial
um okay so
i just wanted to address something here
um
sort of philosophical thing so i'm
uh
okay so
the the result which i'm going to
present is uh
that low degree polynomials are
evolvable okay
which includes say linear functions
linear functions from n dimensions to m
dimensions over all distributions
and
um
okay so again there are degrees there
are many many degrees of freedom in this
model
so you've got n inputs which are protein
concentrations
m separate outputs expression levels of
sorry the n inputs are ex
some way of expressing your environment
the m outputs are proteins that you
express you need to figure out how to
express them
there's
again for each of these outputs there's
an arbitrary function in this class
that's a low degree polynomial
that specifies the ideal input output
relation so again we're quantifying over
all of these
we're also quantifying over all
distributions d in n-dimensional space
and this distribution again represents
the examples that nature presents you
uh
and again a loss function
which given a
how you've responded and how the ideal
function would respond gives you some
penalty
for responding differently from it
and
for now it's the
distance squared
but later we'll talk about any convex
function
um
and again the goal is to win the
evolution game in all cases so we're
qualifying over all these things
and
half the audience i know is going to say
look you've got too many cases nature
isn't this general i only care about
this case can you do this case can you
tell the specific case i don't want to
know about the typical case i want to
know about this case
half the audience is going to say no
this isn't enough quantification i want
to know about quantification overall
possible feedback that the creature can
give the environment and all possible i
mean you know there's many many things
you can add to this
presumably you shouldn't just be
dividing the audience
no
other other views which yeah
two-thirds of the audiences believe in
the first view two-thirds believe in the
second view and there's an overlap
between them no no i mean there's just
one good job either but believe this
right could you have any justification
for convexity as opposed to a general
polynomial time computable loss function
because
um i don't know how to prove it for more
general things and for very non-convex
things it'll probably be impossible
i mean any justification for your name
um
if you're talking about vectors in high
dimensional space distance functions
like l2 or l1
are
a natural thing to consider
um
but uh
no if you've got some natural class of
function set that you you'd be
interested in then this is completely
fair game i just know how to prove it
the whole setup is in terms of
polynomial time computability so one
could
just talk about
uh
loss function which the only thing you
know is polynomial time computer
strong assumptions like convexity
so
um
quantifying over the loss function is a
little bit a separate issue because uh
um
the loss function is more meant to
represent kind of the laws of nature
than sometimes you know physics almost
that it should be something simple and
not um
there's not necessarily a big
computation happening there
um
but uh okay that's an interesting point
just beyond the scope of what i can
prove today okay you kind of want to put
all that into the functions into the
function space great yeah yeah so so the
the place where we can easily
deal with a lot of complexity is with
these
m arbitrarily low arbitrary low degree
polynomial functions
um okay so
i just wanted to
philosophically try and defend
um one kind of
philosophical point from computer
science that again
a good portion of the audience you'll
have to forgive me for going through
this but i think it might be relevant to
uh
to uh some of the rest of the audience
um so
um
okay yeah um
okay so let's play a very silly game
called guess my password
so okay um
what is my password
okay this is my password um let's play
the guess my password game um can anyone
guess my password
how hard is it to guess my password
it's pretty easy
it's pretty easy well look i picked a
really good password like anyone will
tell you it's a really good password how
hard is it to guess my password
um okay well
maybe the problem is that we don't have
enough data okay so maybe i should
collect some more data okay so you know
instead of this
imagine some list of kind of hundred
passwords like this okay so i've gone
out into the lab and collected a lot of
data so now i have 100 pieces of data so
now i have a list of 100 actual
passwords that are you know real
passwords
how hard is it to get my password well
now now things are a bit more
complicated now you only know that it's
one out of a list of 100 things so your
probability of guessing my password is
one out of 100.
but still this really isn't modeling
what's going on if this is if this is
you know if something like this is my
password
then uh
it should be pretty hard to guess
so this is where computer scientists um
where we're forced to instead of coming
up instead of looking at specific data
we talk about
a model of generating passwords so
consider a model of generating passwords
where i have say a 10 000 word
dictionary or very very simple words and
i just
picked two random words in this
dictionary and concatenate them
house
elephant
okay so this is a generative model for
passwords
and given this
how hard is it to guess my password if
i've
generated
a password from this model i choose one
words this ten thousand word dictionary
and the second word from this tend to
have more dictionary and concatenate
them how hard to guess my password
possible
one and ten to minus eight okay one in
ten thousand times one and ten thousand
so
even though you know this isn't exactly
how i generate my password i don't
exactly go to a dictionary and do this i
do something you know a bit stranger
maybe i add one two three at the end
um if we come up if we have a generative
model that's not quite capturing the
exact truth it doesn't agree with the
data you know this is the data this is
our model it's not the exact thing but
somehow having a model that's big enough
um that that generates things even
things that we're not like that i
receive even things that we've never
seen
this gives us insight into how hard the
problem is of how hard these
computational problems with solving are
so
this is the uh
the challenge here so
even though there are specific examples
of functions that we want to understand
how they arose
genetically
the
um coming up with a simple model
like this you know house elephant model
and trying to ask how hard are these
things to evolve
this gives us much more insight than
taking a specific thing and saying look
i i i just want to ex i just want to
guess this password how hard is it to
get this password
deeply confused by the question most
hard problems
biology never solves
almost almost certainly biology never
solves the most hard problems that exist
it solves some hard problems but that's
a very different question from asking if
it solves a particular yeah
yeah yes so i mean again think of these
fish that appear in these mountain lakes
so you know fish don't solve every hard
problem but they solve enough
interesting problems that we need a
general explanation for how fish can
solve problems it's very different
yeah
this is a very important point
i mean suppose this is i mean this is my
naive not computer science way of
thinking about it so i probably will say
something silly but suppose that there's
a huge number of hard problems
and the probability of solving any hard
problem is some small number
close to zero but the number of hard
problems is the inverse of that
probability the biology starts how
solves part problems with a probability
of one but it solves any particular hard
problem the probability of zero
sure um
so i'm just puzzled by the way
you're framing it because
i mean i it's interesting it's an
interesting problem i see that yeah um
again you can talk about this with
respect to the password guessing game
that you know maybe some passwords are
harder to guess than others no
in biology if there's a password and
it's hard to guess that it'll probably
never be guessed but organizations will
be fine well what i'll do like people do
is they hack into biology would hack
into the computer and get it from one of
the meets and i think
so so yeah you know this is supposing i
happen to guess someone in the
audience's password okay um
how far into your talk are you um yeah
i'll
end in five minutes
yeah
i don't need to jump up and down about
results and it's a model which i'm more
interested in so yeah i'm completely
happy just ending here and discussing
yeah um so so okay so supposing i happen
to get someone in the audience in the
audience's password okay supposing i
actually claim that i actually know
someone in the audience's password
what do you guys conclude
i think i'm lucky
that somebody in the audience has a
really bad question
or maybe i happen to know someone in the
audience they told me their password
um
so you know if we've got this phenomenon
that on the surface seems very hard to
do
and it's and then i tell you that
actually i can do it immediately there
are sort of four different possibilities
for how to get around this hardness
result
and it's the same kind of thing here and
if there's a phenomenon which is hard to
do
evolving some specific behavior
then
immediately what everyone should think
about is what are the explanations that
get around the harness results we need
some explanation for this miracle maybe
in the course of your lifetime you've
faced an infinite number of hard
problems and now you're picking the one
that you happen to have solved
oh yes so sorry i really love this so um
maybe over a course my lifetime i've
used 20 passwords and then someone
randomly a computer shows up in front of
me and says look you need to log in
using one of the 20 passwords you've
already used so again this is me
succeeding at a test that you know if a
computer appears in front of me and i
managed to get the password again you
should be impressed you should be
looking for the explanation one possible
explanation is that it's a path that
i've already used so this is an
explanation for say how multicellularity
has arisen in the lab well you know
multicellularity was in the lab only
because it occurs in these creatures 500
million years ago and has been disabled
and now re-enabled so yes so every time
you see creatures succeeding at
something your instinct shouldn't be to
say well it got lucky but your instinct
should be to say well how did it solve
the password problem what which of these
kind of five ways around the hardest of
guessing passwords did the creature use
did it you know was it an easy password
was it um something a path that already
knew in the past and had sort of half
forgotten was it a password that you
know a friend of it you know a password
of a friend of it that you know it's
been communicated to it
this is a coincidence problem i i think
if you extend this you just say okay
you're very impressed by having solved
that problem but if you ask how many
other problems are there which you would
have been equally impressed if it's all
but you failed to solve right and that's
and you only find the one that happened
to have solved one which you're
addressed by right which is that's the
paradox of availability that it's
conditioning upon what we actually see
and things being successful and then it
always looks as if you have something
very impressive if you get something
which is conditioning upon a bunch of
rare events right so i mean
another aspect of this which i think is
worth considering is in some sense
evolvability is talking about what
happens in a fixed environment what kind
of behavior can arise in a fixed
environment
and if you find behavior that seems more
complicated than canonized in a fixed
environment for example a parity
function of many bits
the
conclusion is not oh no you cheated but
perhaps this didn't arise in a fixed
environment perhaps nature somehow led
it step by step to evolve each component
of parity function
so different ways yeah suppose that i
get 10 to the eighth guesses
and then right and the password is in a
space that's of complexity 10 to the
eighth yeah
and then i happen to guess right are you
how impressed are you
he's on the internet there could be you
know almost 10 to the 10 people in the
audience right you get 100 passwords um
i mean it worked in space a huge number
of hard problems and they don't solve
almost all of them so it's not that you
went in and logged in and guessed
somebody's password but that the fact
that somebody did that if there are ten
to the eight people oh
sorry
so if you if you're bringing my number
of guesses up
so look with passwords the number of
guesses i have patience for is kind of
50 and the space is 10 38 so okay but if
you want to give me 28 guesses and you
need to give me a space of 10 to 1
billion genes does that say ten to one
billion genomes of length you know a few
billion
okay so
it gets an environmental complexity
problem it's not a genomic complexity
problem
and he's got the gene that that solves
the problem now if you know what
a huge number of hard problems
and an orgasm happens to solve one of
them
yeah so look if you if you raise the
numbers from 50 guesses and 10 v8
passwords to
10 to the 50 guesses i don't even care
what this number is and you know a
password space is 10 to 1 billion the
problem only gets more strange that
every time you succeed
your instinct shouldn't be well look i
don't want to explain this because there
were a lot of guesses your instinct
should be look it has to have gotten
very kind of fortunate it has gone from
strong hint somehow it has to have had
strong help somehow what are the avenues
that it could have gotten strong health
by i think wait so they're they're not
trying to increase the number of guesses
that you get
right that you said you know the
password of someone in the audience
they're trying to increase the number of
audience members
yeah but i mean i think the point is the
same but just to you know i think though
you guys will talk to each other better
um
so someone asked me to finish my talk i
guess i'll just
sorry skip to maybe
one of the further directions there um
oh okay sure sure um
so um okay
there's a gap between what we can prove
the natural sounding evolution
algorithms um so namely like make random
make mutations randomly in random bits
versus artificial things so if you allow
an arbitrary turing machine to run on
your jeans what can it do there's a gap
between these and understanding how to
get more natural like things to succeed
in more cases this is compelling
um
and uh
yeah there's questions about whether
these natural algorithms can be extended
to more general loss functions beyond l2
and there's a very interesting
connection between uh
what evolution seems to do at least in
simulations and aspects of optimization
that we don't understand so things like
simulated annealing where the ball
doesn't always roll downhill it
sometimes goes uphill a little bit and
it somehow ingeniously succeeds in cases
that rolling downhill won't succeed at
so evolution succeeds in somehow the
same way and understanding exactly how
evolution succeeds in cases like this i
think much insight on simulated
annealing
um
so and again just a kind of
big picture thing so uh
um
if um okay so i think we've discussed
this um
so
i i guess
there's a phrase coined at
berkeley the computational lens what
does the world look like for
computational lens
head this slide here so
um if you look at evolution
um in some sense what what i'm talking
about today and almost the only thing we
know i had to talk about is
microevolution the very short time scale
evolution so if you look very closely at
squirrel's dna um you might catch it
evolving so some t changes to a c
and in some sense this is very similar
to if you look at the computer closely
enough really closely
you can catch it maybe
with an instruction like register two
becomes register one plus seven
and
somehow this doesn't capture what's
happening on your laptop the magic of
your laptop is not captured by by
edition
um the magic really is how do these
local pieces fit together into a much
bigger hole and this is a very different
kind of question to ask
um so so in some sense this evolvability
thing is trying to talk about what what
can you do in one step what's the kind
of evolutionary analog of addition
and really scrutinizing what's happening
with addition is not the right thing to
do the right thing to do is ask you know
well
how do the bigger pieces fit together
and what's surprising what what
surprises us
um
figuring out exactly if you can do
additional addition and multiplication
in one step this is not which what
differentiates an impressive computer
from a non-impressive computer the real
question is
how these pieces fit together in context
which is just a much broader thing which
i'm interested in in general
um okay so
i'll
end here
um thanks
one of the things that i'm confused
is meant to be a kind of dull model
that it might underestimate the class of
problems that
biologically can solve
because biological evolution is capable
of
for example the illusion of the
vulnerability
right so
this
this model is trying to model what you
can learn in one step with a fixed
environment
and uh
people have seen
a reasonable amount of machine learning
in the audience will know that by
analogy in machine learning what you can
learn just given a fixed
environment in some sense is really
limited
and
in some sense the big punchline of
machine learning is that well after
we've proven all these really
distressing upper bounds saying that
well machine learning actually can't do
any of the interesting things that that
we can do yeah i mean you know the
theorems are saying that all the tasks
that we can do are actually impossible
to learn
so the mystery is you know well how do
we learn them
and in some sense the answer is well we
got teachers so you can't learn any
anything interesting in one step but in
multiple steps given the right guidance
even someone leading you along this path
you can learn anything but in one step
there's very little you can learn so
this in some sense attention here that
anything which is any of the really
impressive things that life does have to
happen in multiple steps
and again this is this is the analogy
with if you see the you know fish at the
top of a waterfall they couldn't have
gotten there in one jump
and this makes you look for alternative
explanations i thought your model had
multiple steps
um multiple generations but the
environment doesn't change
yeah
i mean one common question about the
fish one and some analogy there yeah
that you're focusing down there you're
saying okay i can understand this but i
understand this bit and one's been
focusing down on the one should be
really surprised by which i might be
really surprised by it that seems to me
an important part is that if you're
getting an understanding of which things
that may be surprising one can evolve
one can't evolve easily then one can go
and focus on okay which bits are the
most surprising about to understand
those i
the other thing is you said you would
say something about the the
random case versus the worst case
um is that interesting yeah sorry so
that was his password thing that um
this is kind of a typical password but
scrutinizing this typical password in
detail somehow doesn't even tell you
about the general problem of all
passwords and to talk about the general
problem of how surprising guessing a
password is in general
you need to talk about some model for
how passwords came to our eyes in this
dictionary model is a model
which doesn't fit this specific data
which doesn't fit the case that you
specifically care about but somehow
gives you insight into it anyway or the
sort of ensemble how people behave when
they picking passwords right right
really hard to model specifically yeah
like the ensemble of behavior that
people do when picking passwords this is
analogous to the ensemble of crazy
things that life does you are never
going to model every detail of this
there's no hope of it but you can
capture at least something about the
hardness or easiness of guessing
passwords but you know drastic
simplifying things you'll still get some
insight so for example i wouldn't choose
to guess a computer scientist's password
i would choose to guess some other kind
of password
oh yes so i think i'll end here um so
thank you